la chose en train d'ouvrir une porte que
l'on ouvre qu'en certaines occasions
pour accéder à l'escalier d'entre elles
un petit lieu presque secret
[Musique]
perché à 90 mètres de hauteur on appelle
cet escalier l'escalier de dentelle pour
ce garde-corps ciselé dans la pierre
[Musique]
en empruntant l'escalier de dentelle on
s'approche du personnage le plus
important du mont saint michel
l'archange bien sûr il est ici au dessus
de nous sur la flèche à 156 mètres
d'altitude
xavier bailly l administrateur de
l'abbaye il est le gardien de son
histoire est un privilégié il peut
ouvrir les pièces secrètes
habituellement fermés au public
on va dans la flèche alors la flèche
c'est quand même le petit balcon qu'elle
a au frais pour l' aventure
abete
après avoir grimpé l'équivalent de six
étages la flèche le point culminant du
mont saint michel perché à 140 mètres de
hauteur bon ça se mérite
nous sommes ici dans ce que l'on appelle
le belvédère avec une très très belle
vue plongeante sur la terrasse de
l'ouest sur la merveille on voit bien le
cloître on voit tout le village au fil
des époques les occupants de l'abbaye
ont laissé leurs empreintes guerre de
cent ans occupation nazie une partie de
l'histoire de france est ancré ici il
s'agit de graffitis allemand de la
seconde guerre mondiale quand le mont
saint michel était occupé on a ici la
date de 1942 et ce graffiti comme
beaucoup d'autres ici dans la flèche ont
été barrées par les libérateurs
américains après la libération de la
norme
quelques étages plus bas dans les
sous-sols une nouvelle facette de son
passé
plus sombre encore sommes à la porte des
cachots de l'abbaye du mont-saint-michel
sommes pas dans la période la plus pas
dire la plus faste ni la plus brillante
l'histoire du mont saint michel mais
c'est se rappeler aussi que l'abbaye du
mont saint michel a été une prison à
partir de la révolution française et qui
ont été enfermés ici des prêtres
réfractaires des chouans et des
prisonniers politiques comme barbès
entre 1793
1863 c'est plus de 14 mille détenus qui
sont enfermés à l'abbaye du mont saint
michel
mais depuis 1300 en l'abbaye est avant
tout un lieu spirituel
d'après la légende l'origine de l'église
abbatiale remonte à l'an 709
dans un rêve l'archange saint-michel
rend visite à l'évêque saint-aubert et
lui demande de construire un sanctuaire
à son nom c'est par ce rêve que débute
l'histoire religieuse du mont saint
michel
[Musique]